[Music]
adam carolla is one of the very few
funny comedians left in the united
states why
because he's honest and he's brave and
if you want to be funny you have to be
both those things
we had a very long and great
conversation with adam carla recently
for the newest episode of tucker carlson
today here's part of it
how much of what they say the woke
people the people in charge
the president his acolytes do they do
they really mean
so like if you quote martin luther king
and they denounce you as a white
supremacist for doing that
which happens i happen to know do they
really mean it when they say that
no i mean i i can't believe i certainly
i don't think joe biden
means anything well that's right i i
don't think there's anything that comes
out of his mouth that he means
and uh you know when he's talking about
jim crow 2.0 or he's talking about
you know certain i heard him
the other day saying certain nations are
being pulled back or certain states are
being pulled back into a jim crow
where they're going to ask black black
people to count jelly beans before they
can vote
like it's insanity it's reckless it's
irresponsible
it's sort of insane it's really sort of
the equivalent to
your pilot being drunk sort of like well
he's not a bad guy
i know but he's drunk he's flying an
airplane yeah
so he drink he drinks a little you know
what i mean he has a he has a co-pilot
it is kind of that you know what i mean
like well he doesn't want to kill
anybody
yeah i know but he's a drunken airline
pilot that's kind of that's what biden
is doing it's just saying
horrible divisive things that has got us
going at breakneck speed
in apart from one another and
and the politicians have figured out the
corporations
have figured it out that you know cola
and airlines and all that they're all
racing this direction i don't think they
know what the end game is and i the
endgame is power
it's it's it's not it's not prosperity
it's just power they're going to get
more power other people can languish
other people and go fight it out in the
streets they're going to they're going
to
seize control of power and i i do not i
don't believe
i don't believe a thing that biden says
or kamala harris says kamal harris i
don't
she's up there with biden in terms of
does she believe what she says
well one little interesting test to
figure out where they believe what
they're saying
is just go on youtube and see them
saying exactly the opposite four years
ago or two years ago or 18 years ago you
know what i mean you can
just how could they believe what they're
saying you know what i mean like how
many thing that's always interesting
about
like a guy like biden you know he's what
78 years old yes
how many things in your life did you
change 180 degrees on like after your
50th birthday
you know what i mean like you believe
what you believe by 50 yeah yeah
you've kind of figured out where you are
yeah you're there like
most guys it's probably 33 and a half or
something right you know you have some
of
these
kind of kooky thoughts when you're
younger and this belief system and stuff
by the time you pass 40 you're really
settled in with your
your thoughts whether people agree with
them or not those are those are your
thoughts
think about biden past the age of 60
how many flip flops and reverses
of thought he's at the age of 70 or past
the age of 70.
so does he believe it no he doesn't
he doesn't believe it but we're now
entering that new era of politics
what percentage of people who voted for
biden i mean polls show a huge
percentage believe that he was
in decline as a per as as an older man
do you think the people who voted for
him think about that a lot think it
matters
does anyone think it matters no i i i
they wanted to get rid of trump
right and they wanted the opposite we
wanted to go
from uh disco
to grunge music you know we just that's
how we roll
as a society we've got too much mirror
balls and donna summer and
spandex and cocaine we're gonna go right
over here to a tattered sweater
and a guy drinking a mickey's big mouth
and
that's where that's what we did
so you're not that funny unless you're
really insightful and honest and adam
kroll is the conversation went on
it's on tucker carlson today how do you
get it's very easy go to foxnation.com
new episodes out monday wednesday
and friday